l'aide au pôle de haut niveau est une
subvention annuelle versée olig pour
contribuer au financement de
l'encadrement technique et des charges
administratives spécifiques au bon
fonctionnement des différents pôles vous
aussi l'aide au pôle de haut niveau vous
intéresse alors suivez-moi c'est par ici
[Musique]
nous sommes au terrain de football du
lycée agricole de Saint-Joseph ou
s'entraîne plusieurs joueurs en vue
d'atteindre le haut niveau c'est ici que
nous allons retrouver Haussmann gangat
qui est directeur technique de la Ligue
réunionnaise de football sa structure a
pu bénéficier de l'aide au pôle de haut
niveau il va nous en dire un peu plus
bonjour monsieur Ganga bonjour Alors
dites-nous comment l'aide au pôle de
haut niveau vous a aidé c'est une aide
qui a été décisive dans le montage du
projet justement avec l'académie de la
Réunion avec la Fédération Française de
Football et on a pu présenter un projet
concret au département qui nous a permis
de pouvoir faire en sorte que 21
joueuses puissent bénéficier de ce
dispositif et à quelle hauteur s'élève
cette aide et à quoi vous sert-elle bah
c'est une aide de 25000 euros donc c'est
une part importante du budget ça nous
permet de pouvoir bénéficier de
l'hébergement de la restauration
financer le poste d'assistante
d'éducation qui est un poste important
pour nous puisque
au-delà de l'aspect sportif le suivi
scolaire il est important on est sur un
double projet donc ces jeunes filles
bénéficient justement d'un
accompagnement d'un staff avec des
coachs et des kinés et l'aide du
département est primordiale on bénéficie
d'un aménagement scolaire de la part du
collège Achille gondin qui se trouve
juste à côté du lycée agricole où les
filles sont hébergés ensuite elles ont
un accompagnement aussi avec
l'assistante d'éducation pour pouvoir
avoir un renforcement au niveau scolaire
merci Monsieur Ganga
le département grâce à l'aide au pôle de
haut niveau permet à des sportifs locaux
sélectionnés à l'échelon départementale
de bénéficier de l'entraînement intensif
sous la conduite de cadre technique de
haut niveau tout en poursuivant leurs
études bonjour Jean-Éric bonjour
Alexandre alors dites nous comment
fonctionne l'aide au pôle de haut niveau
est une subvention annuelle qui est
versée olig et au comité pour les aider
au niveau du fonctionnement des pôles ou
alors de prendre en charge les frais
techniques et les décharges
administratives au niveau des familles
et bien c'est une contribution qui leur
permet de pouvoir réduire les coûts de
prise en charge de l'hébergement et
depuis 2021 le département propose
également une bourse trimestrielle sous
condition de ressources bien sûr
aux jeunes collégiens qui sont dans ces
structures et qui peut bénéficier de
cette aide et quel sport aujourd'hui à
la Réunion pour cette année 2022 14
disciplines donc sollicité la subvention
départementale des disciplines
collectives le foot le hand on a aussi
des disciplines de pleine nature telles
que l'escalade le surf et enfin nous
avons également des disciplines
individuelles telles que l'athlétisme et
la pelote basque par exemple il y a
quelle hauteur s'élève cette tête l'aide
proposer par le docteur
en fonction des besoins bien sûr de
chaque pôle de 2000 euros à 32000 euros
et c'est une subvention annuelle de
200000 euros qui est proposé chaque
année merci Jean-Éric merci Alexandre
ces structures profitent d'un vrai coup
de pouce financier pour maintenir un bon
niveau de compétitivité tout en couvrant
une partie des frais d'hébergement de
restauration et du suivi scolaire
diminuant l'effort financier demander
aux familles
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide au pôle de
haut niveau n'hésitez pas vous avez
toutes les coordonnées qui s'affichent
sur votre écran le département des
générations c'est fini si vous souhaitez
revoir cet épisode ainsi que les
précédents rendez-vous sur nos sites et
nos réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine nous partons à la
rencontre d'une étudiante qui a pu
bénéficier de l'allocation de scolarité
une aide du département qui intervient
pour le règlement des frais de scolarité
supérieurs à 1000 euros
[Musique]